So this is, um, the Corsen Cervantes, uh,
Don Quixote. Uh, I am Roberto Gonzalez,
each area,
uh,
from comparative literature
and the Spanish Department. Uh,
normally in Spanish.
We go by the first of the two last names.
So even though my email is
robotical dot Echeverria uh,
I am normally known if at all, uh, uh,
Gonzales, officer Gonzalez,
[inaudible], professor [inaudible],
uh, just for your, uh,
general, uh, information, uh,
you will be getting tidbits about
Spanish culture such as the one I've just
given you throughout, uh, the course,
even if this is not a culture
class or a language class,
but, uh, it is important
to, for you to know them.
You will also be getting a good
deal about Spanish, uh, history,
uh, both, uh,
in the lectures and in the assigned
readings and of course through the reading
of the, uh, of the Quixote. Uh,
you will also of course have
to learn a few titles in,
in Spanish works of Spanish literature
that I will be mentioning, uh,
and a and that you, uh, will, uh, uh,
learn in the course of the,
uh, uh, of the semester. Uh,
but that is to be expected,
I guess.
So in this course we are going to read
together one of the on question master
pieces of world literature,
let alone the western Canon as defined
by my friend Harold Bloom in his popular,
uh,
book,
the western Canada where it appears,
uh,
at the very top of the
list paired with a hamlet.
The hot day is a book that
will affect your lives,
not just your understanding
and enjoyment of literature.
I can anticipate that,
um,
Vicky Hall is the first modern novel.
I'd be talking a lot about the novel
modern novel and it'll become clear as we
move along because there are a,
there is a confusion,
uh,
and novel in which according to
Gabrielle Garcia Marquez the Nobel Prize,
a Columbian novelist,
uh,
and novel where there is
already everything that
Novelis would attempt to do in
the future.
Until today,
young Sigmund Freud formed a set
of Advantis club with his friends.
And the Quixote was Jorge.
Luis Borges has is obsession,
bought his ass. You may
know was the great, uh,
Argentine writer,
famous Yan,
what?
Uh,
the late British scholar
considered a donkey.
Haut they one of four myths
of a modern individualism,
you call them.
Uh,
the other been Faust don't
Huang and Robinson Crusoe
in words by good to digital
that Molina and Daniel Defoe.
Uh,
but this is not the most important
thing about, uh, about the book. Uh,
the Hartej has and has continued to be
read by millions of readers in every
imaginable language and we
will be asking ourselves why,
what is it that this book has
that is so meaningful to so many?
I myself have a, uh, answered
the question in this fashion,
in the introduction to the
penguin classics edition that you,
we will be using in this course.
The penguin classics translation
by [inaudible] Rada Rather Ford.
I say they're in that introduction.
The following Miguel disadvantage subway,
the subway that's a masterpiece has
endured because it focuses on literatures
for most appeal to become another,
to leave at typically embattled self
for another closer to one's desires and
aspirations.
This is why I don't be haughty has
often been read as a children's book and
continues to be read by or two children.
Experience and lives,
blows teachers our limits and erode
the hope of living up to our dreams.
But our hope never vanishes.
It is the sows pith the flickering
light of being the spiritual,
the spiritual counterpart
to our DNAs master code.
When they hero regains his
sanity at the end of part two,
he dies as the last chances of
living an imaginary life disappear.
So most life itself,
Don Quixote's,
serene passing reflects
this understanding.
He knows that the dream of life is over.
And I said,
neoplatonist and Christian,
his only hope now is to find
the true life after death.
So much for my own cook, sorry, uh,
for you reading the Quixote will be,
uh,
an event that you will always remember.
And uh, Don Quixote on
Saint Joe, his squire, uh,
will become lifelong friends, uh,
about whom you would think often.
I can predict that safely.
I think. So what is the Hopi
and novel you will say?
Well, first of all to hot,
if it is a novel,
is to Nols one published in
1605 and the other in 1615
yeah.
To gather,
they are known as the key,
much more about the title in a minute.
And knowledgeable people refer to them
as part one and part two or the 1605
Quixote and the 1615 Quixote.
So the first thing to learn,
and I like first things because I like
to build on them from the ground up,
is that the Quixote consists of two
parts originally published separately,
10 years apart,
10 years apart.
But what Cervantes wrote low considered
the first modern novel was not an oval
as we as we know them today,
because novels did not exist as such.
Yet novels developed in
the wake of the Jihad.
So Cervantes could not have
set out to write a novel
in his time
than Toronto's his time.
There were [inaudible] Valerie Romances,
stories about night errands,
a lot more about that in the very near
future pastoral Rollbahn sis stories.
How about fake shepherds?
Picaresque lives,
uh,
what we call today
confusedly picaresque novels.
And brief Novell lay or new vendor that
is long short stories of which Advantis
wrote quite a few on and very good ones.
And we will read some here in this course
to the modern novel would evolve from
translations and imitations
of the [inaudible],
particularly in France and England and
would attain its current form in the 18th
century.
I am very much a historian and I
would like to for you to have a clear,
uh, historical, chronological, uh,
idea of the development of the novel
and of surrenders his own career.
So, uh, take note of this,
uh, chronological, uh,
clarifications that I give you
now.
What may you know about the chaotic,
many of you I suppose come to this course
and intrigued by the name of an author
and the title of a book that
you might have heard about,
but not like most classes,
classics,
not many have actually read in
its entirety, much less studied,
uh, us with both classics. Do you
have probably heard so much about,
uh, the key halted that it
feels as if you had read it?
Many have heard the songs
from man of La Mancha,
the impossible dream, the
impossible dream and so forth. Uh,
perhaps you haven't even seen the
show is quite a good show by the way.
I don't look down upon it. It
is a version of the Quixote, uh,
in an American, uh, mode. Very,
very much an American mode,
but a very good one.
Uh, so many of you have,
I've seen man of La Mancha
have heard the songs. Uh,
uh, maybe you have even read a comic
book based on the, uh, on the novel.
They are coming books based
on, on, on, on an oval. Uh,
others may have read it in a, in a,
in a high school class, parts of it.
Some of you may have read it in
a course like directed studies,
uh, in conjunction with other
western classics such as the Odyssey,
the need and the divine comedy.
Uh, whatever the case may be.
Most of your probably
puzzled by the, uh, uh,
spelling and pronunciation
of the protagonist's name
and the title of the book.
Let me clarify those.
US At modest beginning the first step,
having been to tell you that they
can help these two novels. Now,
the second step is to tell you about that.
The name of the protagonist
on how to pronounce it,
on how we pronounce it in Spanish
and how it's spelled and Hawaii,
the way to pronounce it in modern
Spanish is Quixote d hall day,
no gliding of the, Oh, not
Quixote, Quixote in Spanish.
We don't glide the vows.
They are short and crisp.
Why then that vixen x in English.
The reason is that when the book was
written in the last years of the 16th
century and the first of the 17th the
sound of theJ in Spanish was still in the
process of moving from the show sound
that it had thanks to the influence of
Arabic and we'll worry about that later.
Moving towards the aspirated
of more in Spanish.
That ash,
that sound was then written with an x
in this still to be codified spelling of
the language more than European spending
of modern European languages was not
qualified until the 18th century.
Uh,
for instance,
the word for soap in Spanish,
many of you who know some
Spanish note how boom, uh,
what's written then with an x,
and it was pronounced Chavon
Mexico was pronounced mushy,
Goh and up,
and it was spelled with an x.
That x that is still retains though in
Spanish it is pronounced may Hiko never
Mexico.
Hence the,
the English seeing an x in the middle
of the title of their fantasies book.
The book was translated very early
into English or Irish in 1605,
the first translation appeared
in 16, 11. That's six years.
It's very fast in the 17th century.
So the English team that
acts mispronounced it quick
salt with a sound that it
never had in Spanish.
That is why you have the x in English
and the mispronunciation quick salt.
You follow the history.
Now the French,
meanwhile hearing that
she rendered it Keyshot,
which is still the way they mispronounced
it, the French call it don't keyshot.
I will always say here he halted and
hope that you will learn to do the same
from now on the risk of
sounding a little snobbish,
uh, uh, two English speakers.
But Yalies can sound snobbish if you,
um,
so now a few more basic,
very basic facts about
the title of the book.
The title of a book or a painting is
like the first interpretation by its
author. It is a sort of what we
would call in literary criticism,
a metal text,
the text above the text.
Sometimes though titles can be misleading,
but they're always interesting
and should be examined carefully.
Making sure that you gain access to
the full title of the first edition,
not one that has been tampered with by
editors or the reading public later.
Uh, for instance, the,
the Pickwick papers,
the novel by Dickens was really called
the posthumous papers of the Pickwick
club. And it is interesting
why it is called. So,
um, now be careful also with
the translations of titles.
I will tell you later about some of
the key hotels because translations of
titles sometimes are very
misleading novel by Aleppo.
Uh,
tarpon ta call and seagull.
The last was translated as
explosion in the cathedral,
Wha Wha why?
Uh,
because the editors thought that the
age of enlightenment would sound like a
title of a textbook or something.
So that's the way that they translated it.
So you don't have to be very careful if
you're going to really read something
carefully about the title. So
you go to the real title. Now,
the full,
the full title
of the first part of Don Quixote,
remember published in 1605.
I want to engrave that date on your mind
is as follows,
[inaudible] don Quixote,
the line manager.
You know that the youth
was rendered as a, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, perform the Latin.
So in Henry also Evalgo
Don Quixote Dela mantra.
This is a reproduction of the
actual title page of the first key.
You are seeing it.
Okay.
We are fortunate enough to have a copy
of that first edition at Beinecke library
here at Yale. Um, what do you do?
Okay. All right. So, uh,
let us go over those words one by one.
I can assure you we're not going
to go over every word in the book,
one by one as I'm wanting
to do with the title,
or it would take the rest of our lives
to finish reaching the Chiota together.
So in Henny also does not mean here what
exactly what it means today in Spanish.
You know,
uh,
in Henry also means today
something like a cute, witty,
cute or inventive in 16,
11,
covarruvias rights.
Now it's a name that you're going to
be hearing throughout the semester,
and I'm going to put her on the board
just the last name because it's very
important.
Okay.
He's name was save young,
the Covarrubias your Roscoe.
Uh, he was, uh,
a lexicographer who published in 1611.
The first dictionary of
the Spanish language,
the first dictionary of the Spanish
language called Tesoro. The Lingua cast,
the Yana or Hispaniola,
the sorrows of the Castilian
or Spanish a language.
It's very convenient that go on.
Ruby published that dictionary in 16,
11. Right in between the, uh, the,
the two parts of the Kihatha 16,
oh five, 16, 15, the dictionary
comes in 16 hours, 1611.
So Covarrubias gives us
instead of anthis Spanish.
So this is why it is, uh, so, uh, such
an important book for the reading of,
of, of, of, of is a don Quixote. Uh,
the title itself is interesting because
it shows that Castilian and Spanish,
I wanted the same thing. I'll
talk about that a little. Uh, uh,
more later he writes about in Henio we
commonly call in Kenya a natural force of
the mind that inquires that which through
reason and intelligence can be found
through all sorts of sciences,
disciplines,
liberal and mechanical arts
suddenly inventions and deceit.
Hence we call it,
we call it engineer in [inaudible].
He who builds machines to fight off the
enemy and to attack him in Henry also is
he who has a subtle and sharp wit.
So in Henry also in the title of a donkey,
halt of the Quixote means
heightened kind of what,
or understanding one
that verges on madness.
Recalling what Plato said
in the Republic about ports,
sports being slightly bad in a few years
before the publication of donkey Hartej
of the Quixote,
Eh,
in the year 1575 within
Cervantes is lifetime one,
one day,
not one corn out this one,
uh, so many ones here, but
one worked, they sung quant.
You don't have to remember
this name so much.
And medical doctor publish a very
important book called examine Dane Henio
Spatola CNCS and of a very
long title. Uh, it's uh,
uh, which examined would be the
translation of that, uh, uh,
of that title, uh, uh, in,
in which he studies
different kinds of madness.
So examine the enhanced yours
meant for what they, the sound one,
uh,
an examination of various kinds of madness
of the kinder that covarrubias have
mentioned. So this is to
give you the, the, the, the,
the context of the word in Henry,
also in the title and in Henry also
Evalgo lengthy hotel, a mantra.
Now you got to go,
it's a contraction of e hall,
the Al Gore, which in Spanish means
song of something. But of course,
we are all sons or daughters of something.
But what that meant was you are the
son of someone of some distinction,
uh, uh, a worth the lineage. Uh, and uh,
uh,
Covarrubias says it means the same as
noble with an ancient pure lineage.
That in other words, fewer
of cast of origin, of ilk,
of tradition,
and he dialed go as you
will discover reading.
The first chapter of the
book is a petty nobleman,
someone belonging to the lower
and the ability or aristocracy.
It is important here to note that said,
this does not call donkey Horta
here it Caballero at night.
The novel is that the most basic level,
the story of a petty nobleman who becomes
by dint of his own self invention and
night worthy of using the dome
that is given in the title in 1615.
However,
in the second part of the cohort,
and we will look at that title
page when we come to it, uh, the,
uh, don't get holidays
called the Caballero, um,
for a variety of reasons that I will
explain, uh, at the proper time.
Now, Don don is a form
of address like Sir Sire,
that not everyone had a right to
do expect though Kihatha did not,
or alone Suki handle the
man who became Gnocchi Hall,
not by virtue of his
modest station in life,
but he takes on the dome as
part of this self invention.
You Dad, it goes, in other words,
did not have the right to the dome.
Dome of course, derives from
the Latin. Domino's. Uh, sir,
Lord Master, uh, your readings in Elliot,
the, his, the imperial Spain,
one of the books for the
course will give you further,
much further background on this.
Now key hot day as you will learn reading
the first chapters of the book too is
said to be a derivation
of Kihara jaw or cassava,
something having to do
with cheese or Kay Hannah,
something having to do with complaint.
Uh,
[inaudible] or key Hannah could be
it. He said that is the last name. Uh,
one of them, he Hanoi is the
last name of alone. Suki hell,
the man who becomes Don Quixote,
uh,
the doll go who turns himself
into and Quixote, uh, uh,
these names,
uh,
echo those words mentioned before he
[inaudible] the salar and so forth.
They are not very high
sounding or ennobling words.
Quite the contrary. I hope no one
here has the last name. Kiana Organa.
It happened to me in one of these
classes as I was explaining this,
that a Hispanic young
woman in the class, uh, uh,
how the last name Kianna and
I had to profusely apologize,
but I'm just trying to explain
the title of the novel,
but I am hoping that none of
you is. Last name is Gal. Uh,
now the ending OT OTE,
suffix is a suffix that in Spanish always
refers to something based or grotesque
and sounds, it go from
Gordon Lewis, [inaudible]
granddaughter from ground.
There is a hulking big guy.
A Luxe felty from fail is an ugly cuss.
So kihatha then was meant to
sound a basing and ridiculous,
particularly when pair with dumb,
uh,
with which it forms are kind of
oxymoronic pair. Don't be haughty.
Dongs high son. Nicky hope
this has all of this, uh, uh,
negative connotations.
It also has echoes of [inaudible],
one of the night errands that, uh, uh,
Don Quixote reads about.
And it has also been discovered
that it is the name of, uh,
uh,
of a part of the armor covering the leg.
But the important, uh, uh,
background is what I gave, uh, uh,
before.
Now Mine Cha Logmein Chai is a region
in central Spain in because still that
encompasses parts of the provinces of
Toledo's, you Cuenca and Alba city.
There are maps of Spain in the website.
Uh, and geography is very
important in that Quixote,
particularly in part two.
This is a novel that is very
rooted in a given geography.
Now, Lamont change flag,
iris and monotonous.
It's main product used
to be serious and wine.
But the important thing
here is that it is not,
or it was not until surrenders his work,
a particularly desirable place to be from
a Manchild, some in stain in Spanish. Uh,
it all sounds like a put down being
from La Manchuria was like being from
Bridgeport or buffalo
or Brooklyn or podunk.
Uh,
uh,
now of course this assault
changed with the book and,
uh, now, uh,
the name has and the region has a
poetic air and their theme parks in your
mantra with windmills and all in
Spain, you know, uh, of course.
Uh, but, uh, that was,
that was not what's the rent is
intended when he had no, you know,
they be from La Manchuria.
Uh, it was to be, uh, uh,
in contrast to other nights who
came from more distinguished places.
I am at least of,
I'm at least the gala from Wales or pal.
They Inglot Tara from England
and then don't go the,
you see, this is what it's
supposed to be meant by the title.
You wouldn't have suspected this if I
hadn't told you because you're still under
the influence of man of La Mancha.
Now
the issue of Loki hotters spurious dumb
is significant in broader historian,
a broader historical sense.
By the 16th century,
the glory days of the
nobility were long gone.
Noble men were no longer much engaged
in the military except that the highest
ranks and never seeing actual combat
wars were fought by professional armies.
There was little chance for the nobility
to exercise Marshall like activities,
uh,
which were left now to Josh and to
hunting war became sports for the
aristocracy.
The nobility was on the whole,
on a downturn in Spain because of politics
policies initiated by the Catholic
kings,
Ferdinand and Isabella,
to curtail the power of the
accuracy of the aristocracy. Now,
certain groups at the highest level
of a cluster around the courts of the
descendants of the Catholic
kings just had a lot of power.
But on the whole, the nobility is
on the decline more noticeably.
So in La Manchuria which had a sparse
population of EDL grows as opposed to
northern regions of the peninsula.
So for donkey halted to
practice [inaudible] night,
Aaron tree was a way of reviving the past,
uh,
of reliving a past of splendor and glory.
Now only really available through
reading that you, Albert Romances,
uh, which portrayed
the Medieval world, uh,
when the aristocracy was truly
involved in warfare or, uh,
in, in sports such as hunting of which
don't get hotter, was fond of you.
As you will learn in the
early chapters of the book,
we will have much more on the
[inaudible] side promised in the future.
Now what about the language
of the key holding?
What language did a serve Vantis right?
You say in Spanish? Yes, but
we're in the 16th, 17th century.
Uh,
in the 16th century,
Spain Spanish was undergoing its last
significant linguistic revolution is last
significant change.
And uh,
at the time that the Quixote was written
and published Pronoun Verb Forms,
we're still in relative flux,
but Cervantes Spanish does not sound do
the modern Spanish ear as archaic and
Arcane of Shakespearean English
dose do modern English readers. Uh,
I have a difficult time understanding
Shakespeare on the stage.
Sometimes with my American English,
it does sound the Spanish have Cervantes
though sound quaint and the book's fame
gives Cervantes Spanish
today a formal sound,
but it did not have to its
contemporaries for whom the book was not,
of course,
still the classic if read out loud,
the Quixote is more comprehensible to
current speakers of Spanish from Spain and
Latin America than hamlet is to a
modern British or American audience.
But it, but what language was
it that said this used? Well,
he wrote in Castilian or Spanish,
which are the same as
we learn in covarrubias.
His title Americans have the mistaken
notion that they speak the student in
Spain and we don't know. And the
rest of Latin America, it's the same.
It's the same. It's the same language. Um,
because the alien was the language
of Casteel land of Castles.
Because as the conquest, we will, you
will learn what the reconquest is.
That is the reconquest of Spain from
the Moore's advanced in central Spain.
Uh, as the, uh,
US history conquest advanced castles
were built to secure the territory's,
hence Castille. Uh, and
then Castille became,
as you will read in Elliot, the, the,
uh, the, uh, the most influential region,
political and military above all
of the peninsula. And with the,
uh, with the unification of the
peninsula under the Catholic kings,
it tried to impose this language
on the rest of Spain. Uh,
so you know what the difference between
the language and the dialect is a
language is a dialect with an army.
So, uh, uh, language is, uh,
uh,
the language over a region with enough
power to impose it on other people and
become, uh, so, uh,
there are the wear and our
other languages in Spain,
Catalan Galician basketball engine,
but the Catholic kings and
their descendants in post
Castilian on the peninsula
as much as they could and on the
vast territories of the new world,
what is today Latin America because
of discovery and conquest were mainly
Castilian projects.
Spanish is more uniform as a result of
these policies today than English is.
So what is spoken in the Bronx,
Mexico City and Madrid.
Castilian would you
Spanish is what's spoken.
He's spoken in those places.
So you can erase that, uh,
American prejudice from your
minds if you ever had it.
Uh, it is a true, I mean, I
had a colleague at Cornell,
a very distinguished American
medievalist who would ask me,
in what language do you write
your scholarship, Roberto? I said,
what do you mean in English and Spanish?
He was worried that if I didn't write
in English being a Latin America,
I didn't have a cult,
a language of culture in which I could
write because he didn't think that in
Latin America we had
a language of culture.
It's an American prejudice.
Well,
if Spanish was undergoing its last
transformation in the 16th century,
this was also a turbulent
sanctuary for Spain in political,
religious, social, and artistic terms,
considered that in the 16th century,
Spain settled the new world and beyond
the Philippines and organize a vast
imperial bureaucracy to rule it.
Spain also control parts of Italy and
the low countries and Spain itself was
adjusting to the unification brought
about by the marriage of Ferdinand and
Isabella chief and could
still hear from Aragon.
They created the first modern
state. By the way, you will,
you will find in the Quixote characters
come from various regions of Spain,
uh,
most memorably at the very beginning,
a basket who speaks in broken Spanish.
Because even today,
there are regions in Spain,
as you know,
if you've been to Spain where Spanish
is really not the language spoken,
uh, Galicia and the Basque country.
And Catalonia and so forth.
Now in the religious fears, pain became
the defender of the Catholic Church,
which was breaking up in the rest of
Europe as the result of the reformation.
Remember the reformation
is a 16th century event.
Spain was the bastion of Orthodox
Catholicism and this affected tremendously
it's political, social,
and literary life. In 14,
92 of the Catholic kings
expelled the Jews from Spain. Uh,
and that in 1613,
the Maurice goes the sentence of
the Arabs who were still left. And,
uh,
we will be speaking about that and they
will be a distinct echoes of all of
these movements and political
events in the, in the normal,
uh, one could say that the, the,
the copies and only
the first modern novel,
but the first political
novel in that it is much,
it reflects very clearly
political controversies of its,
uh, of its time. In the social domain,
there was a significant
population drain to the new world.
The social mobility costs by the
deliberate erosion of the aristocracy by a
crown bent on centralization and control.
You will find as you read the book,
that the characters move through
areas that are really the populated,
uh, and this reflects this,
this demographic reality.
Uh,
the new bureaucracy provided ways to
attain wealth and power that threaten the
status of the old and powerful
aristocratic families as
well as the traditional
independence of provinces.
And fifth dumps that dated back to
the Middle Ages in the literary world.
Spain's greatest splendor
came at this moment,
uh,
in the,
in the waning of the renaissance and
the emergence or are off of new modern
forms and joggers. The,
the 16th century opened,
uh,
actually just before the 16th century
in 1499 with the publication of
[inaudible].
That's a word that you should learn here.
Um,
on was followed by with the emerge by
the emergency of the picaresque in La.
Sorry,
your Miss [inaudible] was the first
what we call a picaresque novels.
Uh,
1554.
And
uh,
they're emerge.
What came to be known as the Spanish
go media for the Spanish theater.
W there were not all comedies, but
it would call the compendia. And, uh,
these were written by a low pay,
the Vega and name that you might want
to keep in mind because he was a very
prolific writer who was
also Cervantes rivals.
Okay.
He may have written 700 place.
How many of this change we were
right there. You Sonia Lopez,
right dose in a month. It's amazing.
Uh, he was an amazing writer,
a very powerful and a Cervantes,
had a very tense
relationship, uh, with him,
um, import to the 16th
century, so in Garcia,
so that Rebecca, and then you
will see in the book many times,
and it's many followers.
The late great blossoming of the
Petrarchan tradition, you know, pay truck,
uh, and the development,
uh, from the Petrarchan,
the powerful strain of mystical poetry,
particularly in diverse of
Saint John of the cross.
Um,
so this,
the 16th and 17th centuries are what are
called in Spanish literary history as
the Golden Age.
It was also the Golden Age in painting.
If you have been to the Prado Museum
in Madrid, you will see what I mean.
We wouldn't be talking a great deal
about, uh, Spanish painting here,
particularly about Velasquez.
Now the hour,
a little philological excursion about
the title of the book already reveals a
number of things about the hotel and
about Spain. You may wonder Arabic,
what about what the Arabs
have to do with Spain? Well,
the Arabs occupied Spain for
eight centuries from seven 11.
These are good dates to remember
to 1492 when Granada fell.
And that was the last bastion of Arab,
uh,
power in Spain. And it was taken by the
Catholic Kings Verdun and, and Isabella.
And,
but the ire of left and intelligent,
an indelible mark upon Spanish
history and the Spanish language.
It was not an occupation
in the sense that we,
in addition occupations in
the modern period, uh, uh,
historians speak of a Combi Valencia that
is a living together of this Christian
and Muslim cultures which
involve fighting with each other,
but fighting amongst Christians.
And the Muslims are allied with Christians
are going to let Muslims and so forth,
but they were there for eight centuries.
And what could say that
the Arabic component in the
broadest sense is the main
difference between Spain
and the rest of Europe.
The title of the book already alludes
to that difference because of that x,
but you will see it in many
other ways as you read it.
Um, now you can also glean
from what I have said,
that the Kihatha was translated very
early into other European languages,
which is, uh, uh, who just
already, uh, mention, uh,
1611 for the,
for the English and it went on to
be translated in France. Uh, and,
and so forth.
Uh,
that Quixote became very rapidly that
first edition and 1605 and a European
bestseller, uh, turning Cervantes
who was, as you will read. And you,
when you read from the, the assigned
readings in the case book, uh,
a minor figure, it suddenly
into a great success. Uh,
it never brought him the financial
rewards that he desperately needed,
but it turned into a, into a success. Um,
they say that at the beginning,
in the early years that the hotel was
bread almost universally as a funny book.
It's obviously a misreading. It is
much more than just a funny book. Now,
let us turn now in the, in
this, uh, uh, introduction,
uh,
to the basics.
Do the title to the
protagonist's name in English.
Uh,
all of you,
no doubt I've read or heard the word
quixotic and surely have a general notion
or with meaning.
Uh,
someone who is a [inaudible] says the
Oxford English dictionary is quote,
an enthusiastic visionary person like
Don Quixote or like don't quick soap.
They way that they write it inspired
by lofty and chivalrous cut,
but also unrealizable
ideas, uh, unquote. Hence,
quixotic is quote to strive with
lofty enthusiasm for visionary ideas.
How many authors or books,
uh,
or characters have entered
common usage in this way?
Actions or people can be done
task Kafkaesque revelation,
but are any of these
as common as quixotic?
Dan Task always refers to the
inferno and conveys a sense of gloom,
a fire burning sinners and
all of that is done task.
CAFCA ask describes a situation in
which a labyrinth of forces appears to
control your, your life and is
applied mostly to do rock procees.
Yale's bureaucracies becoming Kafkaesque.
I can assure you of that revelation.
Less common means uncontrollable
appetites. Most the time,
most of the time referring to gluttony,
he had a revelation dinner,
but you risk really sounding snobbish.
If you say that you had
a revelation dinner, uh,
even if you're a Yalie,
but not saying quixotic quixotic
is really part of the common usage.
Uh, if pressed, I bet anyone
of you could give, uh,
a TV guide,
abstract of the book,
even those who haven't read a word of it,
it would go something like this.
I made this up. Middle aged man believes
that he can become a knight errand.
Like those he has read about in chivalric
romances and takes to the road with
sanctuary. A peasant had his
choir to set the world are right.
Software's many defeats
but remained some bout.
That's the whole novel right there in
encapsulated and you can put that on a TV
guy or something. I, I have, uh, uh,
the fantasy that you can do that with
any book, no matter how complicated,
uh, try it, try it with the Bible,
the Odyssey or something like that.
But, uh, but I think
that it was a chaotic,
it works and that is what people have in
their imaginations about the, the, the,
the Jihad.
Now,
general knowledge of this kind is
the aura that surrounds the classics.
It can become a temptation
not to read them. As a result,
this sort of vague knowledge also has an
undeniable influence on those who read
them.
It is nearly impossible to read a classic
innocently unless you are a complete
illiterate. Um, besides, if,
if you have read, uh, in some
ways you have read Don Quixote.
If you have read the adventures
of Huckleberry Finn or
if you have read madame
Bovary or if you're a red,
the cafcass metamorphosis because
the influence of the Hilton,
all of those works is so great that in
a sense you have read it through them.
Very few literary
characters have these aura.
I wonder hamlet of course, Faust, uh,
remembering what a young watts said,
king lear don't.
One Oedipus come to mind.
Uh,
can you think of any others
there? There, there are very few.
There are a few within each
literary tradition. For instance,
a huckleberry Finn in the American,
uh,
context [inaudible] vaginal,
but perhaps in France.
Why is it a don Quixote has such
currency as a kind of literary myth?
I think that there's hardly
another secular book two,
which we come with more preconceived
notions and expectations.
It is also one of the very few great
works of world literature that is also a
children's book. As I said
in the paragraph on my
introduction, I read it first.
It was read to me as a children's
book the first time that I, uh, now,
uh,
is it a kin to a modern in secular Bible,
Miguel de Una Muno,
the Spanish philosopher,
uh, read Don Quixote as if it
were a kind of secular Bible.
And I have the feeling that my friend
Harold Bloom does the same, uh,
the kind of New Gospel, the Gospel
for the modern age. Why not?
You have to get something out of the
cohort they relevant to your own lives,
I think, or you're going to be
wasting your time here. Believe me.
Uh, I can't tell you what that is. You'll
have to find out for yourself. But,
uh, why, uh,
why can't it suggest something relevant
to you or why has it for so many over so
many years now I gave my
explanation in my, uh, in that, uh,
first paragraph to my introduction
to the penguin classics.
But let me give you a
more detailed one now.
Whatever other more subtle and specialized
answers we give to this question
throughout the semester,
the only way to respond to it is to say
that Don Quixote and bodies the most
modern of predicaments,
the individuals dissatisfaction with
the world in which he lives and his
struggle to make the
world and his desire mesh.
I mean this world,
not our world yet to
come a promised heaven.
Why is this a modern
predicament or crisis?
Because the world is no longer a given.
By the time Cervantes writes the
western conception of the universe,
uh, which was, uh, up to
about the 16th century,
largely based on a combination
of Aristotle and the Bible.
That is to say scholasticism and the
work of Aquinas has been proven faulty.
Think of one major change.
The first part of the Kihatha
is published in 16 or five,
barely over a hundred years
after the discovery of America,
the 113 to be exact.
And the confirmation
that the world is round,
which proved beyond argument or doubt
that much of the legacy of the ancient
world and the Middle Ages
was open to question.
Think of a second major change.
The reformation has challenged the
authority of the Catholic Church and made
political gains in many important
European nations don't key hot.
This is not a struggle between
the individual and the gods.
They fight against cosmic abstract
forces us in Greek tragedy.
It is not as in Dante human desire
transformed into the yearning for us,
a blind trust and dental vision casting
a universe of perfect coherence,
the machine of the world.
It is instead the struggle
of an individual against
the tractability of a world
in which he lives the world
redolent with imperfections of the,
with the imperfections of the material
coding the temporal flow that carries it
further and further away from ideas.
Does that seem to be two to exist
only in the individual's mind?
Uh,
as hamlet says,
the world is out of sorts and
I'm here to make it right.
This is what a Don Quixote,
uh,
says the novel says George Loukakis,
the Great Hungarian critic is the epic
of a world that has been abandoned by
God, that novels, heroes,
psychology is demonic.
The objectivity of the novel is the
mature man's knowledge that meaning can
never quite penetrate reality,
but that we thought meaning reality
would disintegrate into the inessential
into, into the nothingness
of innocence. Reality.
This is very abstract language
of, uh, of, of, of, uh,
of rue cashew was a neo Kantian.
Uh,
but I think the important thing
that you remember from that is the,
that is a world abandoned by God.
That is not a,
it's not as a god centered
world anymore as in Dante, uh,
that that moves through.
There are other, uh,
uh, less abstract, uh,
definitions of the Quixote global
definitions that I am fond of. Uh,
the one by Larry Nelson that I
quote in my introduction to which,
which goes in crudest terms,
the formula of Don Quixote,
maybe express as the pairing of with tall,
thin idealist with a short fat realist
and setting them off on a series of
hazards in previous fiction,
parents of characters who almost
always been young friends or lovers.
These new however simpler arrangement
together with the Motif of bud literature
influencing life constitutes a primal
and influential glory for Cervantes,
a curl airy, uh, issue to
the question of individuals.
Mal adjustment to the world is
another crucial modern concern.
The perception of reality
and the organization of that
perception into something
that we can be considered the truth.
The way that modern criticism has labeled
this in the Quixote's perspectivism.
The interpretation of reality depends
on the perspective of the individual,
meaning in gross terms,
that one's interpretation of the world
is colored by one's background station in
life, reading these tires
and experience in general.
There's a hilarious series of episodes
when donkey hoped it takes the basing
from a barber, puts it on his head and
says that it is mom Breanna's helmet,
a famous helmet from the
epic tradition. And uh, uh,
in one of the episodes in the,
in the ensues a scholastic lag discussion
about whether this thing is a basin or
a helmet,
uh,
which is of course a funny,
a reenactment of the, of the issue of
perspective is in what Don Quixote,
uh, is a helmet. Others is
a, is a barbarous basing.
This is at the core of, of, of,
of the book or the core of
much of the humor in the book.
This idea of the various
perspectives don't be haughty, uh,
sees giants and Sancho sees
windmills on the clash,
uh, repeats itself
throughout, uh, the book.
But this points to a very
important issue in, in, in, in,
at the beginnings of modern philosophy,
having to do precisely with the
perspective of the individual on our own,
on reality and not,
uh,
not a perspective that has to
be determined by received, uh,
ideas. So, uh, this is, uh,
these are some of the issues that will
come up during the semester as we read
the haughty. Please do the reading, uh,
as I have a set it out in the, uh, uh,
in the syllabus. The syllabus, as you
know, is on a new website. You can, uh,
uh, downloaded from the website
and there you will find a,
uh, all of the, uh, uh, all
of the readings in, in detail.
I want to go over very
briefly over that syllabus,
although you don't, uh, a habit, uh,
and also want to have you meet with the
two tas so you can begin to try to set
up meeting meetings for
the, uh, uh, sections.
Now let me go over the
requirements for the course too,
because I'm sure that you are eager
to learn what the requirements.
Uh, we'll be, uh,
now at midterm
and a take home final exam
for two page papers.
For years.
I have been using this technique for
papers, but each paper is only two pages,
500 words,
no more and no less two pages
because I want something crisp.
And to the point, uh, an idea, I will
give you the topics of the paper would,
which you can devise your own
particular topic, but just to,
so you don't have to begin
Vicki hotter the novel written by me.
This is a right to know you're
writing for me and giving you, uh,
what I hope to be as sharp original,
uh,
take on the topic that I
give you so far of those. Um,
and then, uh, you're required
to come to class prepared to,
we will have discussion after my lectures
in the last 15 minutes of the class.
Uh, and uh, you will,
you are required to come to the sections
as well where you will be graded on
your performance, uh, in the, in, in,
in intersection, the grade distribution.
You will find that in the, in the
syllabus is 40%. That's your papers,
20% of the midterm, 25 final exam, 15
attendance and so forth. You can get it.
And uh, it's uh, rather, uh,
conventional. Do you have any questions?
Yes.
The books are available at Barnes
and noble and uh, under, uh,
the number of the course.
And the books are a city.
Uh, the transfer, the
Delta in the translation,
uh, the, uh,
Imperial's pain and the case book
that I edited with the criticism.
Now there is also available a
Spanish edition of the Kihatha.
If you are going to read it in Spanish,
it's the same one that is
available for Spanish six 60.
That is the graduate seminar.
Uh,
you can buy both if you want
to play around with them.
I have to say that I am not an entirely
happy with Mr Rutherford's translation.
Even though I wrote the introduction, I'm
not happy with any of the translations.
Um, uh, really, uh,
is in a translation as good a
smallest from the 18th century.
And Rutherford, uh, what I wrote
the introduction, uh, I had, uh, uh,
a bitter exchange through the publisher
because I want him to change a few
things, but he's an Oxford professor
who's very antiquated and, uh,
um, uh, I hadn't changed, but I will,
I will be pointing out the shortcomings
of his translation as we move along.
Um,
but I mean that's what we have to deal
with because if you're going to read it
in translation,
do the translation.
But Ed Grossman that it's also
circulating a lot. It is my friend.
Uh, it's a little bit better perhaps. Uh,
but I liked this one because
it has my introduction,
which I think is better than Harold
balloons for [inaudible]. It had,
was a very dear friend of mine.
So this is why I,
I chose again to go with the
rather for, uh, translation.
Uh, so any other questions?
The books are there. The uh,
the website has all the information
you could possibly want.
My office hours are on
Fridays from 10 to 12. Uh,
I am not particularly fond of emails,
um,
because I don't want you to do at
two in the morning, I have an email,
a professor,
one salary through about this idea that
I have for a paper and don't expect that
I'm going to answer the next day because
I got a lot of emails. And, uh, so,
um,
I am,
I'm much more of a fund of a personal,
uh,
meeting. You come to my office
and we talk about this. Okay.
Uh,
any other questions?
Well, if not, uh,
we are going to now pause so that
you meet with Elena and Dina,
uh, who are distinguished
the students, uh,
Elaina and Spanish and Portuguese and
Dina and comparative literature. Um,
Elena, as I said, he's
from Maddy, Conte in Spain.
Dina is from Russia,
from Moscow itself.
Oh, no, no. You are from somewhere
in the back lands of, uh, of Russia.
Uh,
Siberia perhaps.
So could you, uh, meet with them now?
Um, tried to begin to set up a meeting
because I know it's very complicated,
so some games in touch.
Okay.